il ya quelques années
j'habitais une maison écologique en
taille dans un hameau écologique en
bretagne j'étais alors leur fondateur et
rédacteur en chef d'un magazine
spécialisé sur la construction
écologique
ceci explique cela
il y avait souvent des visiteurs qui
venaient voir ces drôles de maisons et
leurs drôles d'habitants un jour j'ai
reçu un groupe de marcheurs pour leur
faire une visite du lieu
l'un d'eux âgé d'une vingtaine d'années
n'arrêtez pas de remettre en question la
taille des maisons qui l'entouraient
d'accord elles sont écologiques est très
belle mais alors qu'est-ce qu'elles sont
grandes
agacé je leur répondais que la mienne ne
faisait que 120 mètres carrés que
lorsque toute la famille recomposée
était là nous étions quand même 5 qu'il
y avait en plus un espace bureau et un
chat mais il n'en démordait pas quand m
c'est vachement nord ça m'avait
turlupiner et pendant plusieurs semaines
après j'ai essayé de me convaincre du
contraire
mais trop tard la graine était semé deux
années plus tard au printemps 2008
c'est-à-dire il ya presque dix ans donc
presque 60 ans pour mon chat j'ai décidé
d'écrire un article sur le petit habitat
au cours de mes recherches je suis tombé
sur un type incroyable
''j'ai schaeffer un américain qui avait
construit sa maison de 9 m² sur une
remorque
bon je suis rentré en contact avec lui
pour avoir des photos et là ce fut le
coup de foudre avec cette année à tous
cette minuscule maison en français à
vrai dire si je remonte quelques années
auparavant lorsque j'avais 23 ans
j'étais déjà totalement fan d'un
philosophe américain qui s'appelle henry
david thoreau il avait construit sa
maison de 14 mètres carrés sur les bords
de l'étang de walden un concorde dans
loin de boston jeff schaffer 10 s
inspirer de taureaux j'étais donc
naturellement conquis j'ai lu tous les
écrits de jay fehr qui comme sa maison
en avantage d'être petit puis j'ai
téléchargé toutes les images de taille
n'est house que je pouvais trouver sur
internet
ça y est la graine venait de germer pour
autant pour autant il m'aura fallu
attendre encore quelques années avant de
passer du rêve à la réalité
nous sommes au début 2013 alors que j'ai
longuement médité sur mon parcours de
vie en regardant la mer à côté de la
paix laquelle j'habite est désormais en
normandie
je me suis dit que mon heure était venue
mais non pas pour finir entre quatre
planches
je vous rassure mais pour commencer une
nouvelle vie
une adorable maisons en bois
j'ai alors passé en revue toutes les
jouer aux lois françaises
pour savoir comment construire puis
déplacée et enfin stationner ce
minuscule maison j'ai dessiné mais
premier plan en n'ayant que quelques
photos de taille naouss américaine sous
la main
oui j'ai remarqué que les américains ne
construisaient des techniques avec de
toutes petites cuisines car il ne
cuisine pas beaucoup il fallait donc
relever ce défi typiquement français de
construire des tiny gastronomiquement
compatibles après tout cela je suis allé
voir un ami du charpentier afin qu'il
m'aide à concevoir la structure de la
première thain et aos française les deux
mois de chantier furent un vrai bonheur
un couple d'amis arboriculteurs bio
m'avez accueilli dans leurs vergers
j'étais au milieu de centaines de
pommiers en fleurs à quelques mètres
d'un marais survolée par des cigognes à
quelques kilomètres de la mer un coin de
paradis
le jour des amis venus me rendre visite
ou me donner des coups de main et le
soir je commençais à prix les met à
faire pour les faire rentrer dans mon
futur espace de vie de 10 mètres carrés
avec une mezzanine de quatre mètres
carrés et oui ma maison est à peine plus
grande que votre chambre ou que votre
salle de bain avoir même que votre
dressing
ma maison est minuscule et pourtant
c'est une vraie maison
alors avant d'aller plus loin je vais
vous me mets un aperçu de son volume
imaginez que je rentre chez moi ce soir
à tiny home sweet home
quel bonheur de rentrer chez soi après
avoir passé une si belle après midi au
théâtre de clermont ferrand à mon canapé
rouge sur lequel j'ai l'habitude de
poser mon petit sac à dos oh mais il
fait un petit peu frisquet il va falloir
que je pense a rallumé mon poêle à bois
de poche
mais au fait qu'est-ce que je vais
cuisiner dans ma cuisine gastronomique
mans compatibles ce soir je sais pas
j'ai oublié de fermer la porte de la
salle de bain et des wc ce matin en
partant je devais être un brin stressé
allez savoir pourquoi
il faudra aussi que je relève mes mails
mais peut-être qu'avant je vais grimper
sur banide than in hell à aller de mon
escalier ici pour aller me reposer 5
minutes
voilà maintenant vous voyez mieux à quoi
cela peut ressembler à l'intérieur et
extérieurement une taille ni a la
particularité d'être construite sur une
grande remorque ce qui lui permet d'être
tracté par un fourgon ou une bonne
voiture
ma maison peut donc bouger est même allé
jusqu'à 80 km heure sur autoroute alors
tout à l'heure je vous disais que la
taille ni est une vraie maison c'est une
vraie maison car elle a tout d'une
grande
une terrasse une porte d'entrée ouverte
une cuisine entièrement équipée un coin
salon un espace bureau une salle de bain
des toilettes une bête jeanine pour le
couchage
elle est bien isolé elle est conçue
comme ses grandes soeurs allemandes ou
suédoise en ossature bois avec une
excellente étanchéité à l'air ce qui
fait qu'elle ne consomme presque trois
fois rien ça peut
time minimise également les gaines
électriques et les tuyauteries
elle est donc intrinsèquement très
économe en énergie alors je vais me
permettre maintenant de répondre aux
trois questions que l'on se pose assez
souvent sur l'état est né et que vous
vous posez peut-être vous même
à cet instant précis la première
question
mais quelle est la différence avec un
camping car alors la principale
différence c'est que là timing est conçu
pour un usage permanent c'est une maison
et non pas pour un usage saisonniers les
autres différences sont la qualité des
matériaux utilisés
la conception le prix 50 % moins élevés
et l'esthétique
et puis il n'existe presque pas de
taille n'est semblable
on est ici plutôt dans du sur mesure une
taille ni correspond à son ou ses
habitants
ce qui m'amène à la seconde question
mais à combien peut-on vivre dans cette
minuscule mignonne maison alors il y en
a qui décide d'y vivre seul et là c'est
le grand confort à la limite du luxe
et puis il ya ceux qui tentent
l'aventuré à deux ce qui est parfait
pour expérimenter le véritable amour
enfin et bien à d'autres notamment les
amis belges qui tentent l'aventuré à
deux avec leurs enfants ils peuvent
assez goûté aux joies de l'éducation
bienveillante dans l'infiniment petit et
d'après ce qu'il me raconte ce n'est que
du bonheur vient enfin la troisième et
dernière question qui est mais si je
devais vivre en taille ni fois pas mois
mais vous qu'est-ce que j'en porterai
avec moi comme à faire c'est le fameux
passage obligé à tous les candidats à
une vie en taille n'est trier ses
affaires et ne conserver que les cent
ciels
c'est à l'époque j'avais pris une
bibliothèque comme celle ci afin
d'étalonner le volume de mes affaires
qu'il rentrerait dans ma future maison
je vous rassure néanmoins ustensiles de
cuisine et vaisselle n'était pas compris
dedans gastronomie française oblige vous
l'aurez compris donc tous les jours je
rajoutais quelque chose dans cette
bibliothèque des vêtements des livres
des bibelots et quand elles étaient
remplies et qu'il y avait encore des
biens que je voulais conserver alors je
devais faire un choix est ce choix c'est
celui de les 100 ciels l'ailé parfois
difficile mais il est indispensable et
une fois dans ma taille ni je me suis
rendu compte que si j'avais envie de
m'acheter un livre ou que quelqu'un me
ferai quelque chose que je voulais
garder alors je devais enlevé quelque
chose de matinée
c'est le principe des vases communicants
un objet entre un autre sort alors
finalement matawinie a invité à vivre
mieux avec moins et la logique
d'accumulation matériel qui est celle de
notre société la plus de prison une
visite dans un magasin d'ameublement ou
de décoration me laisse totalement de
marbre
si un jour vous êtes invité par un ami
qui vit en taille n'est plus à portée
surtout pas quelque chose de matériel
ça pourrait créer chez lui un cas de
conscience terrible surtout s'il s'agit
de la collection complète de la pléiade
ou des 3350 épisode de plus belle la vie
en coffret collector n'ont apporté lui
plutôt un bon petit plat maison fait
avec amour tout en dégustant ce plat
vous apprécierez alors comment le
moindre espace est optimisé ce qui fait
gagner du temps sur le quotidien tiens
j'ai oublié une fourchette
il suffit de tendre le bras tu peux me
passer le sel te plaît un quart de tour
et le voilà et après le repas
vient l'heure du mini rangement
éventuellement du mini ménage car tout
est mini dans une minuscule maison
certes faire son lit
accroupis sur la mezzanine n'est pas
chose aisée et requiert un brin de
souplesse personnellement ça me donne
une très bonne raison pour ne pas faire
mon lit
imaginez alors que cette maison finit
par vous faire gagner du temps
cette denrée rare et précieuse dans
notre monde qui va à 100 à l'heure un
temps que l'on pourra remettre à profit
pour se reconnecter avec soi même avec
les autres ou avec la nature et
d'ailleurs si vous choisissez de mettre
votre taille né dans un coin de campagne
vous serez sans cesse invités à aller
mettre votre nez dehors
parce qu'en plus techniquement il est
très compliqué de faire les cent pas
dedans pour autant on ne se sent pas à
l'étroit dans une tenue car elle possède
un grand nombre de fenêtres
ce qui fait que le regard peut s'en
aller au loin sans jamais être stoppée
par un mur qui plus est allé se coucher
avec des neiges altaïr et vega dans la
fenêtre de toit ou être baigné par la
lumière de la lune est une expérience
cosmique absolument grandiose
grâce à son grand nombre de fenêtres la
taille ni se transforme également en
excellent observatoire pour les oiseaux
ou les animaux et en parlant d'animaux
justement je dois vous avouer que j'ai
parfois un côté un peu ours est alors
matinée house se transforme en tanière à
ours
lorsque nos approches jeu grand mail où
je grogne mais ça ne dure pas vraiment
longtemps car vivant tiny c'est
également vivre dans un esprit de
partage et de communication
d'abord parce qu'il faut une route
suffisamment dégagé pour faire surtout
les maisons de cap m 32 ans et deux
mètres cinquante cinq de large
ensuite parce qu'il sera plus facile de
tirer un tuyau d'eau et une rallonge
électrique de chez un sympathique voisin
tout proche s'il vivre en tennis et
sortir des sentiers battus
vivante année c'est aussi créer du lien
avec les personnes qui accueillent votre
maison d'aubade sur leur terrain c'est
le cas de bernard un bricoleur de génie
homme à tout faire qui pose sa taille ni
trois ou six mois chez des gens en
échange de menus travaux
ils découvrent ainsi de nouveaux
paysages assez régulièrement et se fait
de nouveaux voisins heureux à chaque
fois et ça sent jamais déménagé
ne pourrait-on pas imaginer ensemble que
dans un futur très proche
les tiny puisse également venir
remplacer les logements sociaux ou
servir d'hébergement d'urgence et se dit
compris dans des zones non
constructibles
on pourrait également imaginer que les
tiny sont regroupés ensemble afin de
constituer de petit hameau éphémère ou
pas est toujours respectueux de
l'environnement souhaitons alors que
demain la taille ni et sa place comme
nouveau type d'habitat et nouvelle façon
d'habiter car cette minuscule maison
croyez-moi a un potentiel gigantesque
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]